trailer Matt wall show the corrupt and
morally bankrupt American Academy of
Pediatrics has announced new guidelines
for dealing with childhood obesity no
surprise they recommend drugs and
surgery we'll talk about that and the
medical industry's decades-long campaign
to medicalize every aspect of the Human
Condition also the doj is investigating
after classified documents from Joe
Biden's time as vice president were
found stashed away I guess we have to
impeach Biden now you know those are the
rules plus schools across the country
reinstate masking policies and M Ms
Empower women with all female candy what
the hell exactly does that mean we'll
find out all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
administration's New Year's goals are to
tax spend and turn a blind eye to
inflation if this is at odds with your
goals which it probably is if you're
tired of the government playing games
with your savings and your retirement
plans then you need to get in touch with
the experts at Birch gold today for over
5 000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold in a tax
shelter retirement account Birch gold
makes it makes it easy to convert an IRA
or 401K into an IRA in Precious Metals
text Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim your
free info kit on gold and then to talk
to one of their precious metal
Specialists with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Walsh to 98 98
98 and protect yourself with gold today
that's Walsh to 98 98 98 today
between that reaction to covid and their
full-on Embrace of gender ideology
nearly every major medical organization
in the country has completely
discredited itself over the past couple
of years I'm not sure that we've really
ever seen an industry so quickly and so
thoroughly torch its own credibility in
this way granted we're facing an
Institutional crisis in the west where
almost all major institutions have
forfeited the Public's trust but the
medical industry sets itself apart
because of the dramatic and seemingly
seemingly sudden nature of its moral and
intellectual collapse and because the
consequences of the public losing
confidence in the medical industry of
all Industries are especially dire
the public may still have faith in
medicine the science of medicine but
they don't trust the people charged with
developing dispensing and prescribing it
and why should they
worst of all the specific area of the
medical field that has conducted itself
the most shamefully and destructively
is that area which deals with children
in particular the American Academy of
Pediatrics which is the largest
Association of Pediatricians in the
country has gotten it disastrously wrong
on every important issue for the past
several years and counting pushing faux
medicine and faux treatments and putting
ideology ahead of science every step of
the way the APA of course pushed school
shutdowns during covid
masking for children even now
recommending the Cova vaccine for six
month old babies that's the apa's
recommendation
and of course it is one of the principal
promoters of gender ideology in the
country giving a rubber stamp to
whatever the extremist World
Professional Association of transgender
Health has to say and as wpath
guidelines recommend castration
mutilation and sterilization for ever
younger gender confused children so too
then does the APA
of all the once respected organizations
that have been ideologically captured by
the far left and become these grotesque
discredited husks of what they once were
the APA perhaps sets itself apart and
it's not done it's not done yet
uh CBS News has the latest quote
children struggling with obesity should
be evaluated and treated early and
aggressively including with medications
for kids as young as 12 and surgery for
those as young as 13 according to new
guidelines released on Monday the
long-standing practice of watchful
waiting or delaying treatment to see
whether children and teens outgrow or
overcome obesity on their own only
worsens worsens the problem that affects
more than 14.4 million young people in
the U.S researchers say left untreated
obesity can lead to lifelong health
problems including high blood pressure
diabetes and depression waiting doesn't
work said Dr ihuma ineli co-author of
the guidance on childhood obesity in 15
years from on the first guidance on
childhood obesity in 15 years from the
American Academy of Pediatrics what we
see is a continuation of weight gain and
the likelihood that they'll have obesity
and adulthood
For the First Time The group's guidance
sets ages at which kids and teens should
be offered Medical Treatments such as
drugs and surgery in addition to
intensive diet exercise and other
behavior and lifestyle interventions
said anelly director of the center for
health healthy weight and nutrition at
Nationwide Children's Hospital in
general doctors should offer adolescents
12 and older who have obesity access to
appropriate drugs and teens 13 and older
with severe obesity referrals for weight
loss surgery those situations may vary
so as we've seen the APA loves nothing
more in this world than performing
medically unnecessary and potentially
dangerous elective surgeries on children
who cannot consent to them or fully
understand their long-term ramifications
it's like their favorite thing to do
apparently they aren't you know able to
get their fix with just gender
transition surgeries and so so now
they've moved over to the area of
obesity
and and what sort of supposedly extreme
situations might warrant weight loss
surgeries for minors
well CBS news also provides a helpful
example and uh and let's listen
Rose Garcia says for as long as she can
remember doctors told her she was
overweight what did the doctor or others
tell you to do just to exercise and eat
better she struggled unsuccessfully for
years then at age 15 she developed
hypertension and became pre-diabetic I
visited my doctor and I told her that I
wanted to lose weight but I wanted help
I knew I couldn't do it by myself with
parental permission she finally tried
bariatric weight loss surgery last June
along with counseling for emotional
eating since then she has lost more than
90 pounds did you look in the mirror and
think who is that my clothing was a big
big sign I would put on my carrot
dresses and they were too big and it was
really really surprising to me the new
guidelines from the AAP recommend better
nutrition exercise and face-to-face
counseling treatment may also include
weight loss drugs and surgery for
adolescents who meet the criteria but
for many families medication and surgery
are not covered by Ensure insurance if
they have insurance what do you think
about these new guidelines I think that
it's a
right direction
the right direction
but we gotta we have to operate on even
more kids
now you notice a couple of things about
the girl in that clip if you're watching
on the video podcast the first is that
she was not morbidly obese at least when
she was especially when she was younger
they show pictures of her when she was a
younger child uh they said well she's
been struggling with her weight since
she was a very young child
they show the picture she was chubby
moderately overweight
the kind of overweight that can be quite
easily handled with modest diet changes
and a reasonable amount of exercise
it's very easy to deal with
second she says that that doctors
initially told her to eat healthy and
exercise but she doesn't say that she
actually followed those recommendations
you know so and and we know that she
didn't because anyone anyone who eats
healthy and gets exercise will not be
overweight
okay that's the case for every person on
Earth and if you're listening to this
saying I'm an exception to that no
you're not
okay if you if you if you eat less than
you're eating now and you eat better
than you're eating now and you get more
exercise than you're getting right now
you will lose weight you will everyone
will
now we hear a lot about alleged hormone
issues and other medical complications
that cause people to gain weight
uncontrollably and yet the fact remains
that eating less food or better food
will result in less fat on your body
this is a matter of simple science and
it's the reason why most third world
countries do not have an obesity
epidemic
the people don't eat a lot of food in
those countries and therefore they don't
get fat if it was if it was possible
that genetics or hormones could make you
morbidly obese regardless of what you
eat
then we should be we should see starving
450 pound Ethiopians but we don't
weight gain is a simple formula if you
consume more calories than you burn you
will gain weight if you burn more
calories than you consume you will lose
weight
it's not complicated
and therefore losing weight is not
complicated
though it may be difficult
there's a difference between difficult
and complicated
difficult not because there's any sort
of complex math equation involved but
simply because developing healthy habits
requires discipline and discipline
requires effort and effort can be hard
especially in a culture that encourages
laziness
effort is always at least going to be
harder than no effort
okay the easiest thing is to put in no
effort
and the the the difficulty level will
increase with each extra bit of effort
you apply
difficult not complicated
living a healthy life
in any sense of the word healthy
physically healthy mentally healthy
spiritually is difficult in our society
especially but there is no substitute
for just doing the difficult thing
either you will do it and have the life
you wish to have or not
I mean it's your choice it is your
choice
and in the end there is nothing a doctor
can do to compensate for your refusal to
make the right choices
or rather if there is something they can
do to compensate the negative
consequences in the long run will vastly
outweigh puns slightly intended the
benefits
now every doctor in the country
and every member of the APA knows that
everything I've said so far is true they
know that anyone can lose weight with a
healthy lifestyle they know that the
Obesity epidemic is an epidemic of
people living unhealthy Lifestyles
choosing unhealthy lifestyles
or if their children were talking about
very often these are Lifestyles being
chosen for them
their parents feeding them garbage
putting them on a couch with video games
and TV and whatever and screens
yeah and and again
every doctor knows that all of this is
true yet they have embraced the Obesity
as a disease model of care anyway where
the fat person is treated as though his
fatness was inflicted upon him through
no fault of his own
rather than telling the the parent of
the obese child that they should feed
him better food
instead they now treat the obese child
as though his obesity is a virus or a
cancer
as though it is something that he you
know like contracted
an illness inflicted upon him which
which must now be surgically removed
like a like a tumor
the important thing to understand is
that the medical professionals involved
in instituting this change of approach
they know that their reasoning is bogus
they know it they went to medical school
they know why people get fat
they know how people get unfat
just like they know the difference
between males and females and how binary
and immutable those identities are but
they're now operating within their
medical field as if they do not know
these things
this is a philosophical decision
and we must understand what the
philosophy is
the medical field has long since decided
and this goes back many years okay so
it's actually not just in the last
couple of years it goes back many years
the medical field decided that human
beings are helpless automatons with no
free will no capacity to make choices
are to change and no agency over their
own lives
okay that is the that is the assumption
that the medical field as a as a whole
operates on
it is an industry run by extreme
materialists who believe essentially
that the human mind basically doesn't
exist certainly the soul does not exist
we are the product of chemical reactions
we are governed by these reactions
entirely and so literally any problem we
have anything we suffer from can be
solved chemically that's the way they
look at it this is a process that has
been ongoing for decades and it began
principally in the psychiatric industry
where every bad habit is an addiction
now and every addiction is a disease and
every uncomfortable or inconvenient
human emotion or behavior is a mental
illness and every mental illness is a
disease
the psychiatrists have spent decades
cataloging and medicalizing the entire
Human Condition prescribing psychotropic
drugs to treat everyone who behaves in a
way that falls slightly outside the norm
the norm as defined and determined by
them the psychiatrists
they have done this for so long with
almost no resistance from the public
and mostly because the public has bought
into the program
or been drugged into it as the case may
be
the psychiatrists have been lying to us
but for many people it's a comforting
lie it's a convenient lie it's a lie
that absolves the individual of all
responsibility
if you're doing something you shouldn't
be doing and you're destroying your life
and your family in the process it's only
because you're addicted and it's not
your fault because it's a disease and if
you're experiencing difficult emotions
well then take a drug and get rid of
them because human beings are not
supposed to feel those sorts of feelings
all of this rests you know all of this
rests on a on a whole precarious pile of
philosophical claims and assumptions
that make no sense and that fall apart
under the slightest scrutiny
but most people do not scrutinize them
because they're afraid of the burden of
personal responsibility they'll end up
with if they reject the psychiatric
industry's claims
now
that's psychiatry
my point here is simply that when you
start seeing doctors prescribing diet
pills and gastric bypass surgeries for
chubby 13 year olds treating their
obesity like a cancer that cannot be
cured anyway except with medical
interventions you should know that this
sort of extreme medicalization of The
Human Condition this this treating human
beings like pre-programmed robots who
cannot be expected to change their
behavior this has all been going on for
a very long time
and the stage has been set for many
years
and the average American tragically has
gone along with it up until now
there may reach a point I think we've
already reached the point
where the average American starts to
object
but the question is
whether it's simply too late
now let's get to our headlines
if you own a business the past few years
have uh to say the least I've been a
bumpy ride from covening lockdowns to
bite inflation you could probably use a
break and Innovation refunds can help
with that if your business has five or
more employees and manage to survive
covid you could be eligible to receive a
payroll tax rebate of up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee says in a
loan there's no payback it is a refund
of your taxes the challenge is getting
your hands on it how do you cut through
the red tape and get your business the
refund money well you got to go to
getrefunds.com their team of tax
attorneys are highly trained in this
little known payroll tax refund program
and I've already returned one billion
dollars to businesses they can help you
too they do all the work with no charge
up front and simply share a percentage
of the cash that they get for you
businesses of all types can qualify
including those who took PPP non-profits
and even those that had increases in
sales just go to getrefunds.com click on
qualify me and answer a few questions
this payroll tax refund is only
available for a limited amount of time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
we begin with this headline from the
daily wire breaking doj FBI probing
classified documents from Biden's vice
presidency found at a Biden think take
Think Tank according to reports
so attorney general Merrick Garland has
reportedly assigned the U.S attorney in
Chicago to review classified material
from President Joe Biden's time as vice
president that was discovered at a Biden
Think Tank
CBS News reported that the approximately
10 documents were found at the Penn
Biden Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement in Washington the files were
discovered by Biden's personal attorneys
when they were packing files housed in a
locked closet to prepare to vacate
office space at the Penn Biden Center in
Washington DC
the report says that the FBI was
involved in the situation
now this obviously is uh and you know
people on the right are having a lot of
fun with this and for good reason
because it's pretty hilarious uh that
you know all of this freaking out and
panicking that's that that went on
because Donald Trump had classified
documents
uh and initial speculations that he was
was he taking these documents to
Mar-A-Lago and then selling them the
information to the Russians and all this
crazy he had nuclear secrets and he was
selling them and he was meeting you know
he was meeting uh Vladimir Putin and uh
you know a dark street corner somewhere
underneath a street light and passing
off a briefcase with secrets and then
being handed a you know a bag with a
dollar sign on it in exchange
um that's what we were told
and it was all complete nonsense of
course
and uh as it happens why did why did
Donald Trump have the documents well
just because he he had them he you know
he didn't think it was a big deal
whatever you know it's like just kind of
like a general sort of carelessness
many of us pointed out that um
it it's it's almost certain that Donald
Trump is not the first person who's done
this he's it's almost certain that he's
not the first president or someone in
the White House who has done something
like this
and uh and then we find out oh well
apparently Biden is guilty of it as well
which is great and you know it it puts
the left in a position and it puts us in
a position too
um but the position that we're in it's
their fault
because
and this happens this kind of thing
happens a lot
where you read this story and you think
well like in in reality right who cares
I I don't actually care that he had the
documents it just means nothing to me at
all it doesn't matter I'm sure it's not
a big deal okay I'm sure that there was
not anything Sinister nefarious going on
there are just 10 documents whatever who
cares
that's my reaction that's my gut initial
reaction
um objectively you know analyzing the
situation from what we've been told so
far that's what I would say about it now
you know it we don't know there's still
a lot of information we don't have so
maybe there's something more serious
going on here I tend to doubt
so that's my objective immediate
reaction
but
um
that's not the grace that the left gives
to Republicans and conservatives in the
same situation okay they are the ones
who have set the precedent here
so while I will say but I don't think
this matters and I don't personally care
I'm all about as you know holding the
left to their own standards
which is not a double standard for me
because it's not my standard
I'm saying that you should be you should
have to reap what you sow you should be
held to your own standards
that's the exact opposite of a double
standard for me that's that's uh that is
my standard you have your standards you
have your you know you you uh set the
precedent based on your own behavior in
your own words and you should be stuck
with that
okay it's your medicine you're trying to
give everybody else and now you got to
take a dose of it
which means that in this case
um even if objectively who cares
our reaction has to be well let's got a
call for investigations we need to think
about impeachment this is like we have
to treat it
like a crisis
because that's what the left did and
we're going to hold them to their own
standard
I'm sorry this is this this is a major
crisis now according to you
and that's how we have to treat it
I don't want to have to do that you know
it's like we don't want to have to talk
about this or make it into a thing but
you it see this hurts us more than it
hurts you
is what I'm trying to say
but this is your punishment now now
we're gonna have to make a very big deal
about these documents and I and we do
have to call for and there have to be
investigations into it hearings
everything
it's the precedent you said
all right ABC News
headline more U.S schools Institute mask
mandates as covid cases rise
more schools across the United States
are putting mask mandates in place as
covid-19 cases continue to rise before
winter break districts in New Jersey and
Pennsylvania announced that they would
temporarily be requiring masks among
students and staff members amid a surge
of respiratory illnesses now schools in
Massachusetts and Michigan are following
suit while Chicago schools are asking
students to take rapid tests before
classes start Chelsea public schools in
Boston announced in a letter to the
community the decision was due to
Suffolk County detonated as high risk
for covid-19 transmission as defined by
the CDC
as a result of this designation Chelsea
Public Schools will Implement a mask
mandate masks must be worn in school
buildings at all times except when
eating or drinking
um
meanwhile Ann Arbor schools in Michigan
said it was instituting a two-week
mandate starting oh two weeks where have
we heard that before it'll only be for
two weeks
that sounds familiar but I just can't my
memory is not what it used to be I can't
put my finger on it but I I that sounds
familiar of like coveted related things
where they say it's only two weeks
according to a local affiliate WXYZ the
decision comes after a wave of
respiratory illnesses led to at least
five school closures in December alone
the Ann Arbor Public Schools will
require well-fitting Mass to be worn by
school students staff and visitors while
indoors and aaps schools beginning on
January 9th and during the first two
weeks following the winter break
now you know what they're you notice
what they're doing here
um they the schools that are instituting
these mask mandates which are only
temporary only for two weeks
um
but
they're citing covet as a reason but not
just covet
and they know they can't just cite covet
anymore that's that's not going to be
enough
um because even the most
the most brainwashed of the sheeps of
the sheep rather have most of them have
have realized at this point
that all the masking and all the
panicking that happened was was
completely absurd especially as it
pertains to children so people know that
even people that were you know oblivious
and going along with it for years most
most of them have woken up to that fact
and so it's not they can't just say
covet anymore because they know that
most people will respond rightfully so
okay who cares so there's another Spike
of code whatever
coven's going to be spiking and then
going down and up and down forever it's
endemic it's with us as some of us said
from the very beginning this is always
going to be with us it's just another
thing that's out there now of so many
other things and uh and it's always been
the case that it has very little impact
uh certainly very little serious impact
on children to begin with
but they can't just Sykes Kobe so now
what they're saying is Well it's
respiratory illnesses covid's just one
of them there's also RSV and influenza
and all these other things
now you might point out
that well RSV and the flu influenza
these things have been out there
circulating forever
I mean they were circulating
long before covid and yet there were
never masked mandates nobody ever even
it's not just that there were no mask
mandates in school in response to flu
before covid it's not just that there
were none it's that no one even
suggested it it wasn't even a topic of
conversation it wasn't in the realm of
possibility
but now it is
and what they'll tell us is that
well yeah influenza was out there before
RSV was out there before nobody ever
masked for any of that before certainly
we never had kids wearing surgical masks
in school
uh because of it they'll say yeah that's
true that's true but but we've learned
we've learned from the lessons of covet
and so things are different really what
do we learn
what did we learn about masking that we
didn't know before
so we actually we didn't learn it we
didn't we didn't maybe some people who
are you know oblivious before learned
something but there's there's like no
new information about masks and how they
work and when they work and when they
don't work and there's no new
information
these are all things that we knew before
um
so no we didn't learn anything
it's just that the political situation
has changed masking has become a
political issue and so that has what has
changed and that's why they're now
requiring now and and this is this is
what it's going to be
speaking of things that are always with
us
masking in schools this is just how it's
always going to be forever now
they know they can't get away with
keeping the masks on the kids
permanently in schools but you'll have
masking and then they'll get rid of the
masking and then they'll be back and
back and forth right and that's just how
it's going to be forever
if you don't like it which you shouldn't
then the only real answer is to not
subject your kids to the government
indoctrination camps to begin with
because as soon as you send them into
that building they are at the mercy of
the government they're in a government
building being cared for
or not cared for uh by by government
employees and that's it
all right I missed this yesterday but Dr
fauci was interviewed by CBS News over
the weekend fauci uh retired and yet
still does like 14 interviews per day in
retirement he just he loves the
spotlight that much he can't let it go
he's 145 years old and retired and yet
still sitting down for every interview
he can get
uh Anthony fauci has done he's easily
done more interviews in the last three
years than like the average Hollywood
actor will do in
three decades
and I'm making that statistic up but
then Anthony fauci makes up statistics
all the time so
you know it's what's fair is fair he was
asked in this interview with CBS about
the Demar Hamlin situation
and about the theories and speculation
and the questions really about whether
this his cardiac event had maybe
anything to do with vaccines
and here's what fauci said
Dr fauci I don't know if you saw it but
on Monday night football this week Demar
Hamlin
player for the Buffalo Bills collapsed
on the field
you're not an NFL expert and you're not
an expert on any cardiovascular issues
the player might have had but what I
want to ask you about Dr fauci is
as I want to do in moments like that I
kept an eye on Twitter
and I can't tell you exactly how many
minutes transpired but it was less than
20.
before people on Twitter began to say
well clearly the vaccine caused his
seizure
and that had a multiplier effect on
Twitter as these things tend to do
what's your reaction to that well my
reaction is one of concern about is it
horror borderline more than concern yeah
it's hard that misinformation and
disinformation
uh when you have a platform like social
media that exponentially spreads
in its best form proper and important
and value-added information can spread
which is good yes the thing as a public
health person and as a physician and a
scientist and my my identity as a
physician is the thing that gets pained
the most by that because what that means
major is that yet again another
conspiracy theory complete nonsense is
going to have some people make a
decision for themselves and their family
not to get vaccinated which may cost
them their lives so that's the thing
that's so horrible about it and if you
want to go out spouting nonsense
conspiracy theories and spreading it all
around fine except if it results in a
person suffering and perhaps dying and
that's what happens when disinformation
disincentivizes people to get proper
interventions for a threat like a
pandemic
there's uh some real journalism there
that's some real journalism from uh is
that Major Garrett
so Dr fauci
these people disagree with you how
horrified are you by that
on a scale of one to ten how horrified
are you by people who disagree with you
and thus are wrong about everything
just no attempts like there's there's no
attempt to extract actual information at
all this is just and this is all he
doesn't I I said before that he's done a
million interviews but they're not
really interviews because an interview
is asking questions and then if you
don't get an answer you try and you you
keep trying to extract that information
that's how interview is supposed to go
in that interview this is uh these are
just speeches really
it's all scripted and they're setting
him up they're lobbing the volleyball up
so he can spike it over the net that's
that's all it ever is
um
and and we hear again this this phrase
conspiracy theory which if there's if
there's one phrase that I could ban from
public discourse at this point that
would be the one
even if you disagree with the people
theorizing that maybe the Demar Hamlin
situation had something to do with the
vaccine it's not a conspiracy theory
there's it's that it's it's where's the
conspiracy
now there might have been a lot of
conspiracies surrounding this but the
the theory that okay whether it's right
or wrong
the theory or the question about whether
okay did he take the vaccine and did
that cause a a cardiovascular event
that's not that's just a that's a
medical Theory
now the conspiracy theory
and if you're sure that it's not true
if you're sure that that it had nothing
to do with that
if you have evidence that have nothing
to do with it then tell us the evidence
as I said from the beginning I'm not
convinced
that it had anything to do with the
vaccine we still don't even know if the
guy's vaccinated and I I don't know yet
that that's even been answered now
statistically it's likely because the
majority of the NFL is vaccinated I
believe but they're not all vaccinated
and it was never mandated for players so
possibly wasn't even vaccinated
I'm going to assume that he was though
because if he wasn't then that that
information would probably be out by now
they'd probably be telling us that
um they'd find some way to get that
information out
but we don't know if it was vaccinated
like the simple fact that somebody was
vaccinated and then uh and then ends up
having you know their heart stops and
it's like that doesn't automatically
mean that that's correlation that
doesn't automatically mean that there's
causation
so I'm not convinced by that
and I don't think anyone's really saying
they're convinced it's more like it's a
question
is there a connection here can we talk
about that
can we let's let's what's the evidence
what's going on tell us what you know he
went to the hospital was in the hospital
for several days
one of the people in the hospital say
well the doctors are treating him say
so if you have evidence that disproves
this Theory or this possibility then
present it
but he doesn't bother doing that
and he thinks it's good enough to just
label it as disinformation dangerous
it's going to get people killed
and of course the more you respond to it
that way the more you respond to
questions like this which are totally
valid questions
okay the question about a possible
connection to the vaccine it's a valid
question
um
but the more you respond to those
questions
by trying to shut people down who even
ask them
accusing them of get killing people by
simply asking a question the more you
respond that way then uh the more that
the so-called conspiracy theories will
grow if you're really worried about
so-called conspiracy theories well
that's that's a great way to encourage
them
all right uh quick headline from the
daily wire House Republicans pass rules
for McCarthy's reign with uh one GOP
holder the House Representatives passed
on Monday evening a set of rules that
will govern how the lower chamber
operates for the next two years under
the leadership speaker Kevin McCarthy
all Democrats voted against the rules
package while every Republican except
for one voter to pass it the final tally
was 220 to 213. the set of rules
featured concessions by McCarthy to woo
hard-line conservatives who were holding
up his rise to speakership last week
across more than a dozen votes
um among the concessions was changing
the rules so that a sole member of the
House can file a motion to vacate the
chair
and then there were other concessions
um that we talked about yesterday 72
hours to read the bill single issue
bills
um
investigating you know uh government
corruption the FBI these were all these
were all things that were conceded never
never there never should have should not
have necessitated a concession in the
first place because these are things
that should just happen anyway
and do make note of the fact that
Democrats voted against it right every
Democrat in the house voted against
reading bills before you pass them
okay every Democrat said no we should
not read bills before we pass them
60 minutes though said that uh this was
all very embarrassing the whole process
was very embarrassing and the fact that
there was this negotiation you know in
in
the Republican party and that it led to
this agreement with it's very
embarrassed it should be very
embarrassing to all of us they said
listen to this
the historic chaos in the House of
Representatives this past week
embarrassed not only a party but an
entire nation
a small minority blocked the house from
electing a leader or even swearing in
its own members
vote after vote a would-be speaker could
not bring himself to stand aside in
favor of a colleague
yes it was only for a few days in
January
but if members of the incoming majority
party can't bring themselves to support
a new leader then one wonders what
happens when Congress faces tough
decisions on budgets taxes defense or
raising the debt ceiling actually
governing
I'm Leslie Stahl we'll be back next week
with another edition of 60 minutes
yes my God how embarrassed it's a
deliberative body engaging in
deliberation the legislative branch
people in the legislative branch are
deliberating and compromising
how embarrassing
it's embarrassing that they didn't just
immediately coronate whatever leader was
put before would forward in front of
them by you know the establishment of
their party it's embarrassing I'm
embarrassed by that she said the entire
nation is embarrassed
well I don't know I'm in the nation I'm
a member of the entire nation I'm not
embarrassed by it
it's one of the only times I have not
been embarrassed it's one of the only
times recently I have not been
embarrassed by something happening in
Congress
that's one of the very rare occasions
where I'm actually proud
of some members of Congress for the way
they handled something
in this case specifically the the
holdouts who you know uh stuck by their
guns and got these concessions and got
these chain these rule changes in place
proud of them for that
does not happen very often
is anyone actually embarrassed
if you go up to somebody on the street
I'd like to see uh See I'd like to see
60 minutes
test this Theory and go do kind of like
man on the street interviews
and ask people you know the whole Kevin
McCarthy battle how'd you feel about
that pretty embarrassing right
of course as I said last week most
people will have no idea that it even
happened
but when you tell them about it I don't
think anyone's going to say oh wow
that's embarrassing
they're going to say something like I
don't care I gotta go or they're gonna
say oh okay well that's not what
Congress does they're supposed to argue
about things right
I also wanted to mention this New York
Post headline terrible headline
seven-year-old Louisiana girl was mauled
to death by a neighbor's pit bull that
ran into her family's yard Authority
said Sadie De Villa was playing outside
the East Baton Rouge Parish home at uh 6
30 p.m Friday when the dog barreled onto
the property and viciously attacked her
according to arrest documents obtained
by The Advocate a family member tried to
ward off the dog by hitting it with a
walking cane but the animal couldn't be
deterred
the first grader was taken to the
hospital with multiple dog bites to her
face and severe skull Dam and she later
succumbed to her injuries now
um this is
I believe at least the second pit bull
mulling of a child in the last couple of
days there was a story a few days ago of
a child who I believe
fortunately survived but was
horrifically
um mutilated by the the child was
basically scalped by his scalp ripped
off by by this dog
and this just happens
all the time every year it it just goes
on and on and
um
the it remains a statistical reality
okay I don't care if you're a pitbull
owner and it makes you upset to hear it
and you're going to tell me that oh my
not my pity not my pity he's and he's a
he's a nice puppy he's a nice puppy yeah
well
the reality is that um
the vast majority of fatal maulings in
this country are uh carried out by your
nice puppies okay that's they they are
they are responsible for a vastly
disproportionate number I mean it's not
even close okay
of all the of all the fatal dog attacks
pit bulls account for I don't know you
could look how this is it's something
like 70 percent
or more and um and that's that's of all
dog breeds okay there there are many dog
breeds and you've got this one dog breed
that is that is that is responsible for
almost all of the fatal dog attacks
um and and please don't tell me don't
pull up statistics about dog bites and
say oh actually they they don't bite
nearly as much as uh Chihuahuas or you
know poodles poodles bite a lot more
yeah but poodles don't kill anybody
that's the difference
okay if you're a little Annoying ugly
poodle goes Rogue and the worst it can
do is like maybe you might have to get
stitches on your shin or something
that's the absolute worst case scenario
whereas with a pit bull
if it decides to act as it has been
breeded as it is genetically programmed
to act then it will kill somebody
and very often it's not even going to
kill you as the owner's going to kill
somebody else someone else who didn't
choose to take this animal on didn't
choose the risk now you could say all
you want well I'm going to buy a pit
bull and adopt a Pit Bull and I'm going
to take on the risk it's not just the
risk for you you are assuming this risk
for on behalf of everybody else in the
neighborhood if your neighbor has young
children you've decided that this risk
is worth taking not only with your own
life but with your neighbor's children's
lives too because why because you think
the pit bull is cute
that's what it is it's I think the pit
bull is cute weighed against the lives
of the children and and innocent
bystanders and and various mailmen and
joggers and all the rest of them who who
might be mauled to death by this Beast
there's just no contest here
your desire to adopt an animal that you
find cute does not outweigh the right of
your people in your community to be safe
from these from these vicious animals
and don't tell me it's all about how
they're raised they're all well you know
you keep telling me it's all it's all
about the owner yeah but but the owners
of these Pit Bulls that end up attacking
and killing people
they always say that they did everything
right that they raised the animal right
that they got proper training that's
what they always tell us now you can
assume that that's not true
but that's just your assumption you you
have like this unfalsifiable theory on
your part which is that every pit bull
that attacks another person it's because
it was a bad owner
and how do you know that well because
you just assume that anytime a pit bull
attacks it was a bad owner
you have no evidence of that there's
zero evidence of that you just say it
and what you are disregarding amid all
of this
is that you're disregarding genetics
okay which that's a real thing that
exists that's not uh it's not
Superstition it's not nothing magical
going on there
pit bulls aren't genetically programmed
to be vicious fighting animals they just
are
and so the job of the owner is to do
everything they can to suppress that uh
nature in the wild animal and if you
know something goes wrong then someone
might die and I might add die
horrifically like the most painful and
horrific death you can imagine is what
might happen
this is not like guns are you saying
guns should be banned no I'm not because
uh you have a constitutional right to a
gun you do not have a constitutional
right to own whatever animal you want
and I'm assuming you agree with that
which is why you're not advocating for
people being allowed to have lions and
tigers and like cheetahs you know uh in
in
neighborhoods
what does that tell us it tells us that
you do not have a constitutional
god-given human right to own whatever
animal you want you just don't there are
certain animals that we say do not
belong in communities and how do we
judge that how do we make that judgment
call well if the animal is is
unreasonably dangerous
then he doesn't belong in the community
and pitbulls I mean how many children do
they have to Maul to death before we are
willing to accept that that this animal
falls into the unreasonably dangerous
category
the other thing too is that guns don't
have minds of Their Own
what's the one thing that gun owners
like myself what do we always say when
people say oh you know go get rid of the
guns
now there's the cliched response which
is true it's guns don't kill people
people kill people well people with guns
kill people but the point is that the
gun is not going to get up on its own
and just go out and shoot somebody
um it's a person has to do that
well you know what dogs can do they can
get up on their own and just go out and
kill somebody because they have minds of
Their Own
they are sentient beings unlike guns
so we just need to pitbulls need to be
banned from from communities it just
that that's the law that needs to be
passed everywhere it cannot be allowed
we need to stop breeding these things we
need to stop allowing them in
communities and uh there really is no
sane argument to the contrary the entire
argument to the contrary is just that
well I like pit bulls I think they're
cute that's the whole argument and I've
had this discussion so many times and
I've listened to the other side and
that's all they got that's it
why don't I want them in communities
well because they are responsible for
killing a vastly disappointment number
of children that's why I don't want them
why do you want them there because I
like them
not a good argument
finally I want to play this for you Dr
Jill Biden PhD has some inspirational
words for women listen
from soft lullabies to battle cries for
justice women nurse and nurture teach
and build lead and dream our world
forward each and every day
I'm going to turn this a little bit like
this
we have never been silent but women have
been silenced
for many women around the world simply
raising their voices a struggle and
they've had to fight for a seat at the
table
when women are left behind or pushed out
it hurts us all
but when women get the opportunities
that they deserve there is no limit to
what we can do right
the only thing more incredible than that
inspiring speech was her address which
was either pixelated because it
contained a series of obscenities or it
was meant to be some sort of tribute to
the game Tetris I don't really know
whatever the case Jill Biden
um Dr Jill Biden PhD is right
women are done being silent
every woman in the world every woman
is done being silent and we know that
because no woman has ever been silent
for more than 15 seconds at a time so
they are really done with it they never
even started being silent that's how
done with it they are
anyway we'll have more about uh female
empowerment in the daily cancellation
coming up but first the comment section
[Music]
proud troll says if you choose to rob a
place then you forfeit your life if you
deliberately choose to carry what looks
to be a gun then you should be you
should expect people to respond as if
you're a threat yeah pretty simple
that's that's how I see it too
um
you know and I of course I say the same
thing about people who uh you know if
someone breaks into your house in the
middle of the night that's why somebody
breaks into your house in the middle of
the night and they end up dead like I I
don't really care about the details um
if it was totally up to me I wouldn't
even I wouldn't even ask any questions I
all I need to know
like right if it's if I'm if I'm the one
calling the shots and uh if I am
Theocratic fascist dictator of of the
country and uh you know there's someone
breaks into your house
they're dead only question I have is
does this person live at your house
no did you invite them in
no
okay that's it that's all I don't need
to know anything else
um and it so
if they were as far as I'm concerned if
they're like coming at you with a knife
or if they're pulling a gun on you and
you shoot them obviously Justified if
you're shooting them in the back as
they're walking away
like that's when we could we could have
a moral conversation about you know not
not all shootings are the same morally
but as far as the law should look at it
you come into someone's house Uninvited
you break in you forfeited your life and
that's it
and uh we're not even going to attempt
to parse it and figure out what exactly
it's just you are in there you made that
decision your life is forfeit
um and that you know what that approach
and that attitude will actually pers
that is a pro-life attitude it preserves
lives in the future because of what it's
going to do it tells other people don't
do this don't break into people's houses
don't turn to a life of crime okay it's
not worth the risk it's not worth the
cost of your life which is what which is
the price you will have to pay
all right
uh
Tim The Tool says my favorite part of
the full Taco Shop video is when the
hero after he finished saving the day
and making the other customers whole
proceeded to return to his table
finishes coffee and calmly step over the
robber and leave I guess I didn't I
didn't see the full video I saw the part
leading the actual shooting and I guess
I didn't watch it to the very end I
didn't realize that that's how it ended
but um
yeah he took care of business gave
people back their money
and uh
and then left
I believe the police are still looking
for him to ask him questions but
you know the only question I have for
him is like what's your favorite beer so
I can buy you one that's that's my
question that would be my if I'm the
police if I'm the detective and I'm
sitting down we finally get him we're
sitting down for questioning in the room
you know at a table much like this one
my only my my only question is Sir uh do
you like ipas are you more of a stout
guy
but you seem like maybe a Bud Light guy
you want one of those okay that's it
anyway be on your be on your way
um locutus says my daughter is 18 so
she's been driving for a couple years
now but when she had her permit I was
blown away at how crappy Driver's Ed has
become she just had to watch videos on
her laptop and pass a multiple choice
test and the driving test for her
license was even worse she just drove
around the block no parallel parking no
highway driving I had to take it upon
myself to teach her about blind spots
merging parking and everything else that
keeps you alive
if I didn't know any better I would
think that the state doesn't care very
much about human life
well I think that you uh
think that apparently you do know better
because you're exactly right and it we
talked about this before with the
driver's test it was it was already a
joke back when I you know took the
driver's test 20 years ago it was
already a joke and it was almost like if
it's let's make sure you could do a
three-point turn and you know how to
make a right turn at a stop sign and
that you know how to parallel park and
that was it that's all they did
and of course most people don't even
know how to do any of those things and
yet still ended up passing the driver's
test anyway and now it seems like
apparently they don't even do any of
that anymore it's just like are can you
see can you see out of at least one eye
um and if you could do that then we'll
give you and eventually even that will
be too much of a bird even that will be
a a bar too high because that's exclu
you know that's that's not Equitable
we're excluding those with the with the
vision impairment
um
it is at the point where there's it's
just like why even do the whole
licensing thing anyway the only reason
to have a driver's license really
uh is if you're going to actually
if there's going to be some process for
obtaining the license to make sure that
you know how to do it and if you're not
going to do that then what's the point
of the license to begin with
uh
lft says you got lucky you managed to
find a good woman and you have enough
money to take care of a family not
everyone is so lucky in fact most aren't
stop assuming that your life works for
everyone
now that's that's another cope that's
that's that is also cope on your part to
hear that oh you got lucky
you know you see someone who has things
in their life that you don't have and
that maybe you wish you had and then you
immediately just say oh well they're
lucky and I'm not oh come on now is
there luck involved to some extent yeah
obviously yes if you're still walking
around on two legs and haven't been
killed or paralyzed in a car accident
that's partly luck right lots of things
could have happened to you that uh that
that so that you didn't have those
advantages right I mean so there's
there's luck involved every time you
walk outside of your house
right you drive down the road you drive
across a bridge
if that bridge the bridge could collapse
one day and that's like no fault of your
own that's just a matter of luck so
there's luck involved in life
um but is it all a roll of a dice
you know the fact that I have uh a
family a wife that I love and kids and a
career that I'm happy in I found some
Financial stability like is that all
just a role that I Stumble blindly into
all of this no
you know it's a it is a a process and
you have to work very very hard
and
if you want financial success you have
to work very very hard for it there's
there's just there's no way around it
for most people
there are rare exceptions of a person
who just you know maybe they're born
with a silver spoon in their their
mouths or they really do get lucky and
everything falls into place there are
rare exceptions but those are the
exceptions
that's why we call them that
for most of us if you want to have a
life worth living if you want to be
happy in life if you want to have
anything worthwhile in life you just
have to work and you have to keep
working at it and you gotta you gotta
you got to keep at it for years and
years and years
where I am where I am professionally
right now it took me 15 years
to get there 15 years
um
and
what you find it's like it's not a
coincidence the majority of the people
that I know and that I've ever met who
are really hard workers and they put the
time in
and they're willing to work and and do
it and just humble themselves and even
if they have a setback or you know there
are Peaks and valleys when they're in
The Valleys they don't get discouraged
they keep at almost everyone I know like
that I know plenty of people like that
but here's the crazy thing almost
everyone I know like that
is is is living a successful life
and almost everyone I know who isn't
living a successful life they're not
like that so there isn't just a
connection here
all right
so that's my uh self-help speech for the
day
you know who hates ads I do the last
thing I want to do is read an ad even
though I'm so good at reading them but
uh I do it because ads help pay the
bills however if you become a daily wire
plus member you can help us pay the
bills and in exchange never have to hear
me read an ad again which is probably a
huge incentive for so many of you that
means no more sales pitch no more
skipping and then having to reverse
because you skip too far and this also
means you'll get to hear other shows
like Ben Shapiro show the Michael null
show morning wire all without ads I owe
a debt of gratitude to the people who
are already members because they were
the reason why I was able to make you
know what is a woman and I'm planning on
doing more and even bigger things in
2023 and your support will ensure that I
make that a reality we need your help
though right now you can use code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans head over to dailywire.com Walsh
to become a member and get this show and
so many others ad free that's
dailywire.com Walsh now let's get to our
daily cancellation
goodbye
we live in a culture that is always
changing always evolving always reaching
greater and greater Heights of Tolerance
and Enlightenment and as everyone knows
the Vanguard of this movement the
Warriors up on the front lines fighting
the hardest for Progress the people we
look to first and foremost for guidance
and insight are corporate Brands and
most specifically candy companies we
would be facing grave civilizational
Peril without the leadership of candy
we would be lost without Candy's wisdom
the ancient Greeks had Aristotle and
Plato we have Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
and Starbursts
our philosophers are more Progressive
wiser
even better you can eat them
2022 was a landmark year for candy
Centric social justice it seemed that
every candy brand was stepping up to the
plate so to speak for example Mars
Incorporated announced in in May of 2022
that Skittles would be teaming up with
glad to bring us Pride Skittles for
pride month now Skittles had for several
years prior turned their Skittles all
gray for pride month to symbolically
represent the Brand's cemented quote
unquote support for LGBT rights
because who wouldn't want to you know uh
eat uh
cement themed candies but in 2022 they
took it up a notch hiring a collection
of LGBT artists to create special LGBT
art for the packaging it's estimated
that approximately from the numbers I
read 98 000 homosexuals were saved from
persecution because of the Skittles
packaging KitKat also spoke out
forcefully in defense of gay rights all
at Wonderman Thompson which is the
consultant firm that came up with this
gay rights campaign explain it here it
is
Canada's lgbtq i2s population has risen
to over 1 million
but hate crimes discrimination and
mental health issues have also continued
to rise
lgbtq i2s Community needs a break and
KitKat wanted to help so we reimagined
its iconic brand identity to redefine
what it means to take a break for those
who really need one
we partnered with Toronto lgbtq i2s
organization friends of Ruby to help
Young People Express who they are
our partnership was launched with a
video that celebrated a full spectrum of
identity and love
[Music]
we created two limited edition KitKat
flavors and sold them at the Kit Kat
chocolatory all proceeds were donated to
friends of Ruby
we also sent the pride bars along with
custom mailers to lgbtq i2s influencers
wow kitkat's traditional slogan is give
me a break which is exactly what most
people say to themselves when they hear
the acronym
lgbtqi2s so this campaign really makes a
lot of sense I suppose it's like a it's
kind of something meta going on here but
as heroic has the efforts of KitKat and
Skittles were they obviously paled in
comparison to M Ms indeed M Ms have been
civil rights Pioneers for a long time
they are the Martin Luther King Jr of
candies some have said last year they
redesigned their candy mascots to be
more inclusive the changes were nothing
if not bold and dramatic most startling
of all the green m m ditched her iconic
high heels in favor of sneakers because
M Ms had decided they could no longer
enable those Legions of misogynistic
perverts who have candy related foot
fetishes all the other Eminem characters
underwent their own makeovers in the
hopes of making them more sympathetic
and relatable to a new generation that's
what Eminem said they wanted we needed
to sympathize with and relate to these
characters because of course it's
important to sympathize with and relate
to
an object that you're about to eat
this ability to see something as human
and yet also consume it will at least
come in handy when we all turn to
cannibalism during the forthcoming
apocalypse I suppose but that was 2022.
now it's a new year and I'm pleased to
report that M Ms will be aggressively
defending their Crown as the world's
wokest candy parade has this report
quote for the first time ever select
Eminem packaging will feature a cast of
all female characters parent company
Mars is releasing the new packaging to
Spotlight Dynamic female Eminem
characters in celebration of women
everywhere who are flipping the status
quo as revealed in a January 5th press
release the limited edition packs
feature brown green and recently
introduced purple and will exclusively
contain brown green and purple candies
the M M's brand is on a mission to use
the power of fun to create purposeful
connections as we work to create a world
where everyone feels they belong
Gabrielle Wesley Chief marketing officer
margs Wrigley in North America said in a
release women all over the world are
flipping how they define success and
happiness while challenging the status
quo so we're thrilled to be able to
recognize and celebrate them and who
better to help us on that mission than
our own Powerhouse spokes candies green
brown and purple to represent the flip
the packaging shows the three female
spokes candies standing upside down
above a note supporting women flipping
the status quo
now apparently there will be milk
chocolate peanut and peanut butter
versions of the new packages which is
good because just like female human
beings as we've learned there's no
reason why the female M Ms can't have
nuts needless to say this latest
campaign by Eminem's
has already been a a source of great joy
and inspiration for women all over the
country and the globe in fact I have
seen this firsthand I walked into my
living room yesterday and uh and I'll
never forget this
um I I found my wife and my daughter
embracing each other and smiling just
tears of pure happiness streaming down
their faces and my wife turned to me and
said she said didn't you hear the news
and I shook my head now like everybody
else I'm on the Eminem email list so
that I can read all of their press
releases and PR statements as soon as
they come out but somehow I'd miss this
one I don't know how and my wife then
took me by the hand and she said to me
they're making an all-female m m package
and I was floored I I didn't know what
to say it was the most amazing thing I'd
ever heard in my life
the courage and heroism of Mars
Incorporated
had once again left me speechless
and then through tears my wife and
daughter they both announced in unison
we've never felt so empowered and
inspired
and together we all we all went it was
it was beautiful
and no doubt a scene repeated all around
the world now
there are those of a more critical
disposition who have ruthlessly mocked
this latest example of what they would
describe as awoke corporate virtue
signaling but these people are nothing
but cynics nihilists even they lack the
purity of heart necessary to fully
appreciate what M Ms have done
they're so jaded they can't even admire
an international corporate conglomerate
brand when it comes up with an uplifting
marketing campaign designed to empower
women and also sell candies with 18
grams of processed sugar per serving and
there are still other critics who you
know they've pointed out that while Mars
Incorporated is empowering women with
purple candy
they're also facing a lawsuit filed last
year by eight Africans from the Ivory
Coast who say that they were used as
slave labor on Cocoa plantations
it's hard you know they say to take
their empowerment seriously when they're
also profiting from the enslavement of
human beings allegedly
and to that I say
yeah but still
the point is that M M's are empowering
everyone
except for the slaves allegedly
and that's what we should be focused on
and that is why once again the critics
and the naysayers certainly not M Ms or
Mars Incorporated
are today canceled
and I will do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope see you there if not talk to
you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]